bachelor in paradise stars Carly Waddell
and Evan bass are expecting their first
child together
[Music]
eg can confirm the couple who fell in
love and got engaged on VIP season three
will welcome their new bundle of joy
next year
Evan tells ET quote we are beyond
excited for this baby to join our family
we wanted to have children quickly and
obviously wasted no time
my boys are so excited to guard and
protect this little one and welcome him
or her to the tribe this will be Carly's
first child evan has three boys from a
previous marriage the expectant parents
recently tied the knot during a
beachside ceremony in Port of AR to
Mexico in June Carly and Evan said their
I Do's surrounded by friends family and
other bachelor and bachelorette stars
even host Chris Harrison officiated the
nuptials the bachelor is a parody of
sorts you know it really it's like
especially paradise this makes fun of
itself and makes one of us
but the cool thing is you can actually
go through a process where you find love